jean marc jancovici donc un homme qui a
été tout à fait précurseur dans ce
domaine excellent pédagogue donc
ingénieurs français qui a créé donc sa
société de conseil carbone 4 et puis et
puis qui nous avait aussi offert un
livre qui s'appelle dormez tranquilles
jusqu'en 2100 et autre malentendu sur le
climat et l'énergie parce que c'est vrai
que à une certaine époque on était très
embêté par tout cela on l'est évidemment
c'est à dire qu'on a on était un peu
comme dans une société à qui on avait
donné une espèce de carte bleue mais
sans compter donc ses consommations
d'énergie et ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre alors on va se concentrer
maintenant sur l'agriculture jean marc
jancovici bonjour à vous bon joueur
faisons d'abord le point le diagnostic
sur l'agriculture
qu'est ce que cela représente on va dire
à la fois dans le monde et en france un
peu en pourcentage d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre l'agriculture correspond
aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre
avec des gaz qui ne sont pas celui dont
on parle le plus souvent qui est le
dioxyde de carbone et qui vient des
moddeurs qui vient des chaudières
éventuellement des cimenteries
l'agriculture que contribuer aux
émissions surtout avec deux autres gaz
dont on parle un peu moins le méthane
qui vient notamment du cheptel ruminants
et des rizières et également le
protoxyde d'azoté qui est un gaz qui est
émis par les engrais azotés de toute
nature y compris les déjections animales
quand on les pense sur le sol c'est pas
ça correspond pas à sa fabrication et à
son édition en si on regarde les
émissions directes du secteur agricole
en france comme dans le monde ça
représente à peu près 20% de l'ensemble
de nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
si on raisonne à l'échelle mondiale
parce que le processus est peu présent
en france on peut légitimement y
rajouter la déforestation qui correspond
à la mise en culture de nouvelles terres
comprend sur la forêt comme on l'a
toujours fait historiquement l'europe a
massivement déforester dans la deuxième
partie du deuxième millénaire
les etats-unis ont massivement
déforester au 19e siècle
parce que la population croît ça et
qu'on faisait des pulls des ferries
combettes et des terres en culture
et si on ajoute la déforestation à ce
moment l'agriculture et sa déforestation
avant monte à 30 % des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre dans le monde
pour vous donner deux ordres de grandeur
en comparaison les transports dans le
monde c'est 15% des émissions et les
centrales à charbon dans le monde ces
20% des émissions donc l'agriculture en
termes d'émissions mondiales c'est le
même problème que les centrales à
charbon aujourd'hui et avec les la
déforestation associés c'est 50 % de
plus ça veut dire qu'à peu près lorsque
l'on est face à notre assiette on
accorde donc 25 % on va dire du problème
qui qui est là si on raisonne empreinte
carbone c'est à dire la totalité des
émissions qui sont nécessaires pour
qu'un consommateur final puisse
bénéficier d'un produit ou service
ce que nous avons dans notre assiette en
france représentent un gros quart de
l'empreinte carbone d'un français est là
dedans la viande représente plus enfin
où le figaro vie on va dire que
représente une grosse moitié plein ou à
moitié vide
parlons-en parce que victimes en vessie
et donc de trouver un peu un peu des
solutions en tout cas des solutions ça
va être à la fois ce que souhaite le
consommateur d'un côté ce qu'elles sont
les possibles aussi quelles sont les
réalités économiques évidemment de vaud
de vos différentes entreprises donc vers
quoi il faudrait attendre jean marc
jancovici pour diminuer ses émissions de
gaz à effet de serre alors si on regarde
ce que nous dit la physique la physique
nous dit que tant que nous n'avons pas
commencé à diminuer la concentration de
co2 dans l'atmosphère
je dis bien la diminuer alors que je
devais elle augmente la température
planétaire continue d'augmenter
il faut savoir que le temps de résidence
dans l'atmosphère d'un surplus de co2
sur une fois qu'on a rajouté du co2 dans
l'atmosphère
il faut attendre plus de dix mille ans
pour que ce surplus s'évacue donc il ya
une inertie absolument considérable il
ya pa association ou réversibilité dans
le changement climatique le change le
climat de 2020 a déjà perdu on sait
qu'il est déjà perdue quoi qu'on fasse
sur les émissions il s'en ira il
disparaître à tout jamais pour le reste
des temps historiques
donc si on veut que le climat arrête de
se réchauffer il faut que les la
concentration si on doit se mettre à
baisser dans l'atmosphère et si on veut
respecter les femmes 2 degrés
de paris de degré d'élévation de
température entre l'ère préindustrielle
et le 10 ans ce qui est une température
à laquelle l'ensemble des forêts
inflammable sera l'ensemble des forêts
pardon sera déjà considérablement plus
inflammable que ce que c'est aujourd'hui
un monde dans lequel les sécheresses
récurrentes ont déjà beaucoup plus
importante que dans ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui donc c'est déjà un monde où
on a eu une adversité fortes liées au
changement climatique
il faut que les émissions planétaires
baisse de 5% par an tous les angles à
partir de maintenant et pour au moins
deux générations 5% c'est le pourcentage
de baisse qu'on a eu en 2020 d'eau sur
terre à cause du coc vide
donc je dis maintenant assez facilement
que lutter contre le changement
climatique à la bonne échelle six
acolytes de plus par an voilà c'est ça
qu'il faut avoir en tête et c'est très
peu compatible quand on regarde les
choses d'un peu près avec une croissance
des productions quelle qu'elle soit bon
alors jean marc jancovici si on regarde
maintenant un petit peu les les
différentes actions de l'agriculture on
a les transports vous avez parlé donc de
l'élevage avec principalement donc le
ch4 donc la rumination donc aux
différents besoins
on va rappeler que nous avons à peu près
dans le monde un milliard et demi de
bovins donc sur terre et 40% me
semble-t-il à peu près des terres où 50%
des ter
2 aujourd'hui mondiale sont déliées donc
à l'alimentation de ces fameux bovins on
a aussi donc les transports on a aussi
donc les différents intrants que ce soit
des engrais ou bien aussi les pesticides
qui est qu'est-ce qui est vraiment on va
dire réchauffe le plus ou sur quoi
peut-on agir
on va dire plus ou moins en priorité
même s'il faut gérer toutes les échelles
alors en fait le pourcentage des terres
est encore supérieure si on rajoute les
pâturages en france on a 80 % de la
surface agricole utile qui est dédié à
l'alimentation animale
donc en fait c'est l'essentiel des
terres sont dédiés d'abord à
l'alimentation des animaux évidemment
derrière
si on regarde d'où viennent les
contributions importantes des missions
de l'agriculture dont j'ai dit tout à
l'heure il ya les émissions directes qui
sont importantes à un méthane et
protoxyde d azote c'est aussi vrai en
france
et puis à cela il faut rajouter des
émissions à l'amont et à l'aval donc à
l'amont il faut rajouter la fabrication
des engrais et les phytosanitaires et
des tracteurs mais enfin là dedans c'est
surtout les engrais qui pèse
phytosanitaires sont utilisés en toute
petite quantité donc même si c'est des
produits pas sympathique ça fait pas des
émissions considérable c'est pas ça le
principal inconvénient à dire et la
première dépense énergétique à l'hectare
en fait quand on regarde les grandes
cultures c'est la fabrication des
engrais azotés c'est pas là c'est pas de
diesel du tracteur à laval vous avez
également une dépendance très forte à
l'énergie et aux émissions parce
qu'aujourd'hui si vous regardez la
france vous avez un camion sur trois en
france en gros qui transporte quelque
chose qui se mange donc la grée la
chaîne agroalimentaire est très très
dépendante des hydrocarbures dans son
organisation spatiale et je regardais
les reportages là qui était diffusée
avant le début du colloque en fait
malheureusement le modèle qu'on a bâtie
en fait très désagréable avec les gens
qui regardent le modèle qu'on a bâti
c'est à dire des coopératives
industrielle avec une chaîne logistique
extrêmement longues qui nécessite de
s'approvisionner sur descamps rayon
d'action est ensuite d'exporter des
produits très spécifiques
non pas du tout diversifier sur des
grand rayon d'action cette organisation
là ne peut pas perdurer dans un monde
sombre en énergie ça marche pas donc les
gens qui font que de débats que de la
betterave à sucre ils doivent
ils doivent se faire à l'idée qu'il va
falloir qu'il fasse autre chose parce
que ça ne marche pas quand on regarde
l'organisation il ya quelques siècles
c'était parfait comme ça il ya quelques
siècles c'est quoi la différence avec
aujourd'hui c'est l'abondance
énergétique alors justement maintenant
comment on pourrait réorienter cela
c'est vrai que là c'est clair et net
d'ailleurs si vous avez vite et jean
marc jancovici c'est parce que justement
vous n'avez pas de langue de bois dans
quelle faute pas sur l'eau l'eau qui va
d'ailleurs le problème est qu'ils aient
déjà le problème d'aujourd'hui et de
demain ça que vous allez en moi pour en
reparler évidemment et que les risques
que tout à l'heure mais ça va être le
trop et le pas assez d'eau que déjà vous
subissez les uns et les autres je veux
pas dire dans un monde idéal parce qu'il
ya aucun mon idéal mais comment on
pourrait ça c'est vraiment des problèmes
politiques
comment on peut réorienter donc ce grand
bateau ce grand navire qu'est
l'agriculture française et donc les
coopératives
alors il ya trois déterminants dont il
faut qu'il faut avoir en tête donc y en
a un qui est qu'on souhaite contribuer à
la baisse des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre c'est un premier déterminant
il ya un deuxième déterminant qui est
même si on ne souhaite pas de toute
façon l'agriculture est très dépendante
comme je le disais de grands de grandes
chaînes logistiques très longue qui
elles mêmes sont très dépendante du
pétrole or l'approvisionnement mondial
en pétrole est déjà contraint de façon
significative le pétrole qu'on appelle
conventionnelle c'est à dire tout ce qui
n'est pas le pétrole de schiste aux
états unis et les sables bitumineux du
canada est déjà en production mondiale
contraints à la baisse depuis 2008 et un
rapport de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie publié en 2018 que dont les
médias l'ont beaucoup moins parler que
d'un certain nombre de chiens écrasés kg
dis très clairement
et puis en europe l'approvisionnement
pétrolier est contraint à la baisse
depuis 2006 et cette contrainte va
s'amplifier donc même si on ne le
souhaite pas de toute façon
l'agriculture va devoir se réorganiser
à la lumière de ce que je viens de dire
et puis il ya d'autres facteurs de
pression
il ya la question d'érosion des sols et
il ya la question du changement
climatique
parce que le climat comme je le disais
pas changé et en ce qui concerne la
france les conclusions sont
malheureusement
pas très sympathique puisque ça veut
dire que nous allons avoir plus de
sécheresse et de canicule
on va aussi avoir paradoxalement plus de
précipitations intenses leader on vient
de s'en rendre compte
cet hiver si ce qui sur des sols nus les
cibles au sol et accroît accroît leur
dégradation
j'ai envie de dire donc il va falloir
que l'agriculture de demain compose avec
tout ça alors une fois que j'ai dit ça
et dont on comprend que la solution elle
est malheureusement inverse d'un certain
nombre d'évolutions que nous avons
connue ces dernières décennies
il va falloir des spécialisés une partie
des régions agricoles
il va falloir raccourcir les chaînes
logistiques il va falloir remettre des
aides pour stabiliser le sol et se
passer d'une partie des phytosanitaires
et il va falloir du coup remettre de
l'argent dans ce système parce que ce
système là a été fait pour être optimal
économiquement en n'étant pas optimale
sur le plan environnemental et la durée
des actifs des actifs naturels et donc
ça veut dire que il faut aussi que les
gens s'habituent à payer leur nourriture
plus cher c'est que par ailleurs une
partie des productions agricoles se
recentre sur quelque chose qui va être
moins économiquement moins performant il
faut rappeler qu'il ya deux siècles
l'alimentation des ménages en france
leur coûter à peu près les deux tiers de
ce qu'il gagnait aujourd'hui si on
regarde juste la partie alimentaire dans
ce que nous payons c'est à peu près 2%
celle ci ou défalqué du ticket de caisse
au supermarché tout ce qui concerne le
magasinier la caissière la construction
du supermarché les dividendes pour les
actionnaires les campagnes de pub les
camions qui arrivent et c'est que vous
regardez juste la nourriture dans votre
ticket de caisse
c'est grand maximum 20% de ce que vous
payez donc aujourd'hui la nourriture ne
vaut rien et il va falloir revenir à un
système malheureusement elle va devoir
va coûter quelque chose c'est
intéressant parce qu on a toujours ce
fils de se dire on a dans notre budget
personnel on doit voir l'alimentation
qui doit tourner autour de 12% je crois
que c'est 13% en allemagne mais la
réalité est ce que vous nous dit c'est
que si on des fal que tout ce que vous
avez dit donc les frais d'entreprises
les dividendes etc
le
les salaires et donc les coûts fixes
on arrive ce serait quoi donc 2 3%
simplement de juillet à peu près
bassière en fait c'est la part de
l'agriculture dans libé c'est à peu près
ça donc c'est à peu près de 3% quand
vous allez au restaurant parce que dans
les 13 % 12 % qui ont été cités il ya 5
% qui sont ce qu'on appelle de la
restauration hors domicile
donc c'est les restaurants d'entreprise
quand il y en a qui en serait le plus
c'est les chaînes de fast food que je ne
devrais pas plus tous les restaurants
etc
et bien quand vous regardez le coût des
ingrédients à ce concert vous arrivez
dans les grand maximum à 10 15% du
ticket de caisse et il ya plein de cas
de figure dans lesquelles c'est beaucoup
moins si vous allez vous payer une
emplette à paris ça coûte 5 euros
c'est rare qu'on vous mettre des au bio
dans les omelettes que vous avez mangé à
paris
et quand vous regardez le prix de 3 aux
sorties d'élevage vous en avez pour un
centime
donc vous voyez bien que l'essentiel de
ce que vous payez n'a rien à voir avec
de la nourriture
donc ce que vous dites et ça ça
évidemment ça peut aussi rassurer donc
nos amis coopérateurs qui nous regardent
c'est que vous vous disiez vous plaidez
vous pour crier quand même une vraie
part qu'ils soient augmentés concernant
véritablement les ingrédients et
concernant les produits mais alors
l'agriculture c'est pas aux gens c'est
pas aux gens qui nous écoutent que je
vais apprendre que l'agriculture c'est
un système long et lent c'est un système
qui évolue à la faveur des
renouvellement de générations souvent
donc si on veut réorienter un paysage
agricole c'est pas la faire d'une
semaine on ne peut pas gérer ça avec du
stop and go en disant qu'il ya un coup
je fais partie par là je vais partir
partie donc ça veut dire que le pays
doit repasser un contrat avec ces
agriculteurs qui s'échelonne sur
quelques décennies c'est ça que ça veut
dire
et dans ce contrat qu'on doit repasser
avec nos agriculteurs il faut leur dire
en gros écouter
on a des choix et donc on est d'accord
pour payer pour ses souhaits donc ce
qu'on va faire c'est que on va se mettre
d'accord pour que les prix en ce qui
concerne les productions agricoles soit
garanti un certain niveau mais c'est un
peu ce que faisait la pac à une époque
contre des modes de production qui nous
paraissent en phase avec les enjeux
alors je vais donner un exemple pour
l'élevage il ya deux fois trop de vache
en france si on veut être sérieux sur
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
par ailleurs éleveur c'est un métier
difficile en particulier ceux qui
vendent leur lait à la grande
distribution c'est un métier très
difficile de jauge de dire de quelle
misère enfin cédé métier dans lequel on
gagne mal sa vie du reste je crois que
c'est une des professions où le taux de
suicide est malheureusement le plus
élevé en fins et voilà c'est c'est dur
beaucoup plus dur que le métier que je
fais moi et donc je serais favorable à
un système dans lequel on leur dirait
pas écouté on va vous allez avoir deux
fois moins de matches on va vous payer
cinq fois plus cher au kilo ou au litre
ce que vous produisez et vous allez
avoir un cahier des charges de type
label c'est à dire qu'on va vous
demander s'il vous plaît de ne pas m dos
gm de ne pas m'être pardon mais pas de
paraître sol de chocolat brésilien qui
engendre de la déforestation de laisser
un peu d'espacé veaux vaches de
méthaniser les dix sièges pourquoi enfin
on se met d'accord sur un cahier des
charges et on leur dit on les charge de
ce cahier des charges un peu comme un
peu comme dans une house est évidemment
quelque part ça reviendrait à faire que
de l'agriculture aoc aop enfin c'est un
peu cet esprit là dans un système dans
lequel on perd est considérablement plus
cher les produits et ou pas de remettre
de la d 2 transformations c'est à dire
faire du live à fait parce que c'est ça
qu'on s'est peut être des prêts dans des
domaines tout transformer soit bon il
n'y avait pas juste en le début de ce
prologue on envoyait cristal union
aujourd'hui on mange trop de sucre et
l'éthanol substitut nos l'essence dont
il va falloir se passer dans les
voitures donc tous les produits
transformés sont pas nécessairement les
bons mais par contre si on veut que les
gens fassent des investissements et se
retrouve pas au bec dans l'eau après
avec leur d'investissement il faut
absolument qu'on retrouve du temps long
et qu'on retrouve une gestion pertinente
du temps long
dans le monde agricole ce que
malheureusement aujourd'hui on a plutôt
tendance à faire inverse puisque en
mettant du marché partout et en tout en
supprimant toutes les touts les
encadrements partout en fait on met du
temps court dans tous les sens c'est
évident que ça peut pas fonctionner
comme ça en tout cas pour moi c'est
intéressant de ce congrès donc faut
aujourd'hui c'est comme ça donc je le
redis qu'on vous a invité donc jean marc
jancovici
qu'est ce qui nous donne quand même
équipe complète nous faut aujourd'hui et
en même temps on est des êtres humains
donc on a envie d'y aller
les uns et les autres la coopérative le
monde agricole comme comme tout le monde
quel que soit donc les domaines du monde
est bien conscient de cette affaire là
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait pour que pour
qu'on n'y arrive pour que l'on prenne
bien conscience alors à la fois de ce
qui se passe et pas être dans un côté
dénis plus ou moins collectif et en même
temps il ya quand même des démarches qui
sont encore possibles ce que je la
première marche de l'escalier je n'en
connais pas de meilleure malheureusement
que d'essayer de bien comprendre le
problème à traiter
donc ça ça demande du temps vous savez
quand on est jeune on va tous à l'école
et puis même au cours de notre vie
professionnelle on va tous de temps en
temps en formation continue
c'est parce que on part de l'idée que
s'il ya des problèmes nouveaux qui se
présente à nous ou alors nouveau quand
on vend 10 1 ou nouveau quand on est en
train d'exercer sa profession et bien on
a d'abord besoin de les comprendre
et puis le besoin de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on peut s'y attaquer avant de
passer à l'action
donc aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire que
la première marche de l'escalier et
celle qui n'est pas remplie enfin goûter
plus exactement c'est de bien comprendre
le problème auquel on s'attaque on peut
pas faire confiance aux médias pour ça
parce que malheureusement je suis désolé
jeudi les médias ne savent pas faire la
même chose qu'un cours ils savent pas
capitalisé ils savent pas vous dire
mardi alors vous avez bien retenu ce que
je vous ai dit lundi dans un an je vais
vous dire autre chose
donc ils savent pas faire ça s'est passé
pas leur métier donc il faut absolument
que le toutes les professions y compris
la profession agricole fasse l'effort et
ça c'est pas beaucoup d'argent de
correctement comprendre les enjeux
une fois qu'on a correctement compris
les enjeux à ce moment on peut commencer
à faire le tri entre ce qui est encore
jouable
et puis là où il va falloir qu'on fasse
son deuil parce que c'est trop tard ou
bien c'est des trucs qui sont pas
atteignables
et puis ensuite on passe à l'action
alors j'ai un exemple
c'est une profession particulièrement
riche donc c'est pas nécessairement à un
exemple qui est reproductible en tant
que tel mais il se trouve que
professionnellement je travaille avec
les champenois donc les producteurs de
champagne
encore une fois je sais pas répond des
équipes partout sont pas à plaindre
économiquement depuis le début des
années 2000 2002 2003 des mémoires
ils ont fait exactement ce que je viens
d'évoquer donc ils ont commencé par
diffuser de l'information dont ils ont
multiplié les conférences les modules
c'est maintenant on peut faire des tas
de trucs des coûts etc
et puis ensuite une fois que les gens
sont un peu tombés de leur chaise en
disant aulas est considérablement plus
enquiquinant que l'idée concentrés ils
ont fait tout un tas de groupes de
travail collaboratif en disant voilà
dans tel domaine comment est ce qu'on
peut faire ceci comment est ce qu'on
peut faire cela comment est-ce qu'on
peut s'organiser autrement tous ensemble
et il ya à l'évidence quelque chose de
très collectif à mettre derrière qui
pour avancer il ya également des deuils
qu'il faut faire des business models
qu'il faut changer
par exemple toujours pour être
désagréable on peut pas dans une
coopérative gagner plus d'argent sur la
distribution des intrants sur la
commercialisation des enfants que sur la
commercialisation des récoltes qui peut
pas marcher
je sais pas si c'est le cas encore de
manière fréquente ou pas mais en tout
cas il ya donc de temps en temps il ya
aussi des géants vêtir déconfit
d'objectifs au sein des organisations
qu'il faut
sur lesquels il faut se pencher et qu'il
faut arriver à en sortir collectivement
voilà donc il ya c'est une démarche j'ai
envie de dire très classique comprendre
de quoi on parle
et puis ensuite commencé à réfléchir sur
la façon de s'en emparer en général
quand on fait ça on en trouve toujours
des choses on trouve le donne pas la
solution à tout et à ce moment pour les
problèmes qu'ils n'auront pas entre
guillemets de solutions et bien il faut
au moins commencer à se mêle pas de prix
où on s'est surpris et vous moi devers
spief de toute façon ce pays'' la
société de l'accepter et bien grand
merci jean marc jancovici pour pour tout
cela
vous l'avez dit ça décoiffe c'est bien
ça y va mais il ya ce mot de connectif
que vous avez employé et ça ça vous est
extrêmement cher évidemment au sein des
coopératives
on va passer d'un canot